[Music]
When I started
, I was desperate to enter the country and remembered it, so I was crazy about it and I didn't think about it anymore
.
I'm wondering what to do
[Music]
ni
Boo Boo and my name are Women Forest
Occupation is a pagan Well Blueprint colony
I've been doing this job for 39 years
Since it is a
company that secures the reproduction of music, I receive No. 50 from various apparel and dye it, so
I also dye articles such as music and white, and I also dye various other recipients
.
Most of the
carefree methods are made by hand, and it is easy to make such a method, so I will make the pattern by hand, so
I combined it with the buried trunk
like that.  The general flow is to stick the music on that iron roll and dye it spicy
.
He had that job, but when
he became the most famous, he would become Hermes.
[Music] I didn't
write anything about how to make Japan like
that, so everything in my head.  It's
convenient
because it's in, but it's a very difficult situation, but there is no technology, so I'd like as many people
as possible. Fortunately, our cancer is coming home now.  I remember saying this, but it's
not a pattern that I can easily do, so if there are people who can do it, I would like to do it if the teaching part remains in the teaching
[Music]